Her low freak bitches about um,
these Nazi furries like Neo Nazi furries.
Well,
the absurd obscure a subculture of furries has a problem with mean any,
any groups of sexual abuse and a lot of Nazi,
I mean,
cut the fucking shit.
Please just please cut the shit.
Please,
please.
I can't,
I can't keep going.
It's just too crazy.
Every day it's more and more fucking weird.
This stuff I can get,
I think this is the same people that watch those youtube videos or make the
youtube videos.
I think the people who make the youtube videos,
dude,
I think it's just like they're,
they're in Asia or somewhere like that and they have a script and they just keep
throwing the script over and over and we're looking for like hidden messages in
the script.
I think the script is probably just fucked up.
They think it's fucked up to have a cartoon character hit himself in the head
with a bottle and I think you're probably right.
Like maybe these fucking child predators,
maybe they communicate on all sorts of different websites.
Maybe they just decide like,
hey,
let's meet on this tire forum and we'll just say things in code and attire means
this.
I mean,
it wasn't that always the shit with pizza gate,
like they thought that they were talking in code.
Like all the conspiracy theorists thought that a slice of pizza meant like a kid
and the youtube one,
I mean them being there being so many of them sort of says that there's money in
it.
They've tapped into the algorithm and they're just beating it to death.
Yeah,
and they just have the same script and they just do it with a computer change.
One little thing,
a little thing here and there and that's what I think it is.
I think it's not as nefarious as everybody likes to thank,
but it's really fucking weird to keep seeing the same video playing out over and
over again with a bottle flies through the hair and the baby gets hit in the
fucking head.
And utilities,
I think the activity was a little weird or when it's people actually people
doing it,
you can't just grab a computer,
make it to where people are.
God damn nuts.
They're nuts and they're out there.
I like furries.
Uh,
I get that.
I have a bunch of outfits that I make videos with and stuff and that's pretty
much what that is.
That's just ice ugly cross play.
Like a role play.
Yeah.
They're having fun yet having fun.
They don't feel like normies right,
I say,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm sure having sex like that,
it's probably fine.
That's Kinky.
Like,
hey,
you're dressed up as my pretty pony and I'm Spiderman.
Yeah.
Probably a lot of that.
A lot of dude on dude crime other wearing these hats.
They're wearing fucking weird animal hats and their bone in each other and hey,
why not man be know why?
Because this is crazy.
So why not?
Why to do it?
Why not do it?
See,
look at that.
Just like a Fox and your fucking each other in a fox is fucking the chicken.
Why not?
Why?
Really?
Why not?
I just,
I don't know.
Why not?
I can't tell you.
Why not.
Why is it okay that people were crazy fake eyelashes and extensions in their
hair and they pumped fat into their ass and put silicone bags and their tits?
Why is that okay,
but it's not okay to dress like a big chicken and get fucked by a big rooster.
Why isn't it,
why can't you pretend to be like a fox in the hen house,
right?
Why not?
Like if as long as everybody agrees,
like,
do you agree to be the Fox?
Okay,
cool.
I want me to pull the dog.
I'm going to be the bulldog mascot,
the big bulldog head and we're going to bone.
They're going to make some,
some Ron Davis.
Why the fuck not
have you seen the movie?
I hadn't,
it wouldn't work down during the movie.
I still didn't like him during the movie.
They asked him,
they asked him.
Do you have any,
uh,
good recollections of when you see t growing up when he's trying to,
do you have any fond recollections of you and cts?
You know,
as a kid and I,
boy,
I was looking at them jobs waiting now where I really,
I really want to hear if he was going to fabricate something,
right?
Because I didn't have man.
And I'm like,
oh,
I want to see with this month are going to say that this questionnaire and he
didn't have anything.
And I was like,
okay,
cool.
You know,
a loans.
But I was ready to stop the fucking movie and just make an ass out of myself.
And like,
no,
that's bull shit.
We ain't mad.
You ain't one fucking time that we ever did anything pleasurable together,
motherfucker and was very go off.
But he didn't have any.
So when he didn't have any files,
okay.
Now that's the same recollection that I hadn't done it,
but I really didn't forgive him until this last heart attack in June.
And what happened then when I had the heart attack in June and it seemed like,
uh,
revelation came to me and he was like,
I'm,
it's not hurting him.
It's not hurting him at all.
My Dad is 86 years old.
He's fine,
man.
He,
he's,
I don't,
he's like,
well,
you know,
I don't think he thinks that he has anything to be sorry for that.
I think he thinks he's,
he's done a fantastic job of raising me.
And,
uh,
I was just waiting on the policy who was never going to come,
but I,
but it was still that hate that I have for him was eating me up.
I had to get that burden off me.
And I think having that labs harder,
I didn't want to die carrying that burden with me of hating my dad.
So I went to my dad and I asked him to forgive me.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Damn.
How did you say that?
What did you,
what did you say?
I said,
you know,
look,
Dad,
I have blamed you.
I told him that I had recently had a heart attack and I have blamed you my
entire life for a whole lot of things that went bad or when you know that I
always blamed you fix and,
and,
um,
and I'm sorry.
Uh,
know I don't,
you know,
I don't want to blame me for that anymore.
And would you please forgive me for carrying this against you from,
you know,
my whole life.
I don't want to die,
you know,
letting you think that you know,
I love you man,
and I want you to know that.
Wow.
Yeah.
How good does that feel?
I can't,
I don't wake up punching,
see any anymore.
I probably be out of breath if I date anyway,
but I don't wake up with those night.
I haven't had that nightmare since then.
Wow.
Yeah.
How did he react to that?
He was,
he was a fully accepting of my iPod.
Pete grace me,
you know,
he was graciously accepted.
My apology.
So yeah,
because I have zero musical talent or zero.
Have you ever tried to actually hold a tune trying to just try this,
try to sing all serious.
Don't laugh.
Try to sync.
Just look at me.
It's embarrassing.
But do it.
Try to sing.
I won't sing silent night.
Holy night.
Try to hit it then do it right and then I'm going to try it.
It's so hard.
So nervous.
It's so vulnerable.
I'm asking you to think two verses,
but isn't it funny that like making noises with your mouth?
It's vital?
Nah.
Oh really?
It's not bad.
Oh,
this
copy that was spring.
Can you get a little power?
Oh,
where's Bra
drought?
What's the rest?
I don't know.
Thinking heavenly peace.
Holy infant.
So tender and mild.
Oh,
so,
eh,
when the PE,
I went immediately to the dish bag,
singer voice that whispery I know,
but you,
but you know what you had on tuned.
Do I think you were,
he was tuned,
wasn't he?
Yeah.
You know what I used to do two though.
I only,
I only told Collin Quinn distillery.
Oh,
when I grew up in these apartments,
Pembrook apartments in Prince George's county,
Maryland,
there was this one bullied,
uh,
who would steal people's bikes and shit and he would start fights and whatever.
And so I had,
I played sports,
I,
you know,
so one of my trophies broke and my mom took me to some place to fix it.
And I did not know that there was a place that existed when I just thought
trophies appeared.
You know,
I mean,
as a kid you just get shot,
right.
So when I saw this was the spot,
what I used to do,
because I was saving my allowance and I would go to the trophy spot and buy like
a karate trophy,
just walk around the neighborhood just long enough for this one dude to see me
who I knew would be like the town crier.
And I would always act embarrassed about it.
Like,
Oh,
you don't understand yet.
And that's how we talk.
We say young and stuff.
And then when my mother got me taking karate and shit,
I'm wanting to stay with them.
Oh,
you,
you wanna cry you nights like that.
Don't tell nobody,
man,
I ain't gonna say shit.
And then I would see.
So then,
uh,
and then like,
you know,
a couple of months ago by,
I go by and by a little bigger too.
Dude never messed with me.
He never met.
Thank God.
No one was like,
oh,
I could fight,
but I did.
You know what I'm saying?
But it was like the word got out enough because nobody knew what I'm saying.
Like if you heard a d a Dude Dicker Ronnie,
that was enough.
Like you didn't want to get embarrassed.
So he gave me like free passage to do,
to be my corny self be out.
You know?
That's a very clever way of handling it.
That's what I did when I saw that store.
I was like,
and this the piece of whom they would like five bucks,
seven bucks,
three bucks,
and then we'll go put it on,
and then someone was acting at an early age.
There's all of that shit.
I said,
I know where he going to be.
As soon as he saw me,
I'd go back and I also,
I didn't want him like a big,
you know what I mean?
That's very clever.
Okay.